hey I have a question do you snack out
of boredom snacking out of boredom is
the ultimate killer because it's going
to completely block your Akita plan okay
and I think one of the problems is that
there's more more people working from
home where you have food all over the
place and the ability to go in the
frigerator and consume the food so any
of other people that are retired and
they have maybe more time on their hands
and just not enough to do and they get
into trouble with eating ok so here's
some couple things number one you want
to make sure you get rid of any junk in
your house anything hidden any junky
candy bars or anything any stash that
you have hidden get that out of the
house and make sure if your family
consumes these foods and they're not on
the keto plan have them either get it
out of the house or hide it from you so
you don't find it
number two realize that as soon as you
give in to a snack it's over because
then you're going to be hungry about an
hour later because snacking increases
the insulin and then the blood Sugar's
drop now you're going to be really
hungry and the next question that leads
into this as you're about to eat the
snack is ask yourself am I really hungry
and chances are it's going to be a no
you're just eating for the sake of
eating okay
so just be aware of that but if you're
not hungry then just don't eat chew on
your pencil or your fingernails now I'm
just kidding okay number four track your
time this is a really good exercise if
you were to track what you do in a given
day and find how much time that you're
just kind of maybe spinning your wheels
or doing things that are not productive
it's going to be a wake up call
what I like to do in the morning and I
use my notebooks here I plan out my
entire day exactly what I'm going to do
and I stack it full and I rarely get
through all the things I want to do but
it keeps me very productive doing the
priorities in my life so plan out your
whole day fill up with things that are
super productive to get things done
okay and then that way it will kind of
keep you out of trouble with having idle
time alright number five
increase your B vitamins from
nutritional yeast if you're low in B
vitamins you're going to find that your
stress level will go up and the
temptation to eat will also go up
because cortisol goes up and your blood
sugars will start being affected by that
number six if you're a late night grazer
and you're tempted when you're watching
TV late at night to eat something make
sure that last meal is loaded up with
enough fat and a lot of greens ok maybe
have your big salad and that so you have
no desire to eat after dinner okay
all right thanks for watching so I want
to know what you're interested in as far
as a future video click the link down
below and share some ideas I want to
hear